the Angels outfielder Mike Trout and
this is probably an odd place to start
Mike but I saw this on the internet
where everybody was raving about a
batting practice session with Shohei
Otani in Colorado at Coors Field where
were you there to witness this
incredible batting practice display yeah
yeah I wasn't on the field I definitely
heard about in some video you know was
definitely the talk of the talk of the
day after VP after BP was over the guy's
got a unbelievable power I not first of
all I'm taking BP and spring out I was
telling everybody we gotta check his bat
looks but is that they I mean you've
seen a lot of guys now hit you know who
holes and some of these other guys where
does Otani I rank with BP power he's
gone he's up there on top probably yeah
I've seen a lot of guys a powerhouse ly
playing with Mark Trumbo is his BP it's
probably up there with him but just you
know Connie goes through a couple rounds
where he's just you know hit the ball
field and then you know last few rounds
he he he turns it on a little bit puts
on a show any interest in the home run
derby what's it do to your swing didn't
really have that from an adverse affect
you know not really you know it's just
it's probably you know I never done
obviously but you know what I've heard
from is just it's just a you know a 10
minute grind of BP swings of Coolmax
wings and you know we we take BP and you
know it's around a five and seven it's
not you know three minutes or however
the process is but you know just I don't
know if they affect what effect your
swing
I'm you know saved us but they're for me
I don't try to hit homers and BP I just
Chinese bar I don't tell ya there's a
few few rounds I try to hit a couple for
one but yeah I try to have a little fun
and mix it up a little bit so he's a
Mike Trout of the Angels joining a Stan
Patrick show how does your dad stay your
dad giving you advice as opposed to
somebody who is admiring what you're
doing if that makes sense like how does
dad stay dad in giving you fatherly
advice yeah he's been the same since day
one ever since I was probably about
probably about 10 or 11 he kind of just
let me do my own thing and you know he
knows he's played this game he knows how
hard it is he knows when obviously when
I'm feeling good and what I would see
what I'm you know struggling up there
and you know this uh this little
positive vibes every once in a while
when I'm what I'm not swinging good and
obviously when he's a dad you know you
see he's very it was my you know role
model growing up and you know just my
guy I always looked up to and you know
just always you know through ups and
downs just supported me and you know
through this process he was he's
definitely you know up there but a lot
of times dads won't allow you to be
better than somebody they saw when they
were playing like Barry Sanders dad
would never allow Barry to be considered
better than Jim Brown because Barry's
dad sold Jim Brown and said you're no
Jim Brown does your dad humble you that
way to say you know I know they're
mentioning this guy but you're not this
guy
yeah no not really no he doesn't he you
know he doesn't really compare me in
anybody he started to tell me to be
myself obviously all these comparisons
are great but you know when you're when
you're compared to the all-time greats
and the guys that like you said he
watched growing up he doesn't really you
know mention anything about that you
know just like I said that he's always
there supporting me did you have a
poster of somebody growing up who did
you idolize growing up Jeter
I was big dataframe you know
but you met Jeter yeah I met Jeter did
you ask for anything
I got I got okay now I know how it
normally goes where you can't ask so you
ask the club' to go ask if you can yeah
is that how it works
no I think I was a second baseman I
asked them okay wait wait wait
so G trolls into second or you roll into
second how I roll into second life let
them okay and then how's the
conversation start it's like a blur now
I don't even remember what I said but
he's also also nervous and so uh are
extra what if a rookie did that to you
not granted you're playing outfield but
if a rookie did that yeah you know I
signed the ball send the ball over when
did you fall in love with the Eagles
since I was really little my dad always
followed them and and we always watched
games on Sundays and just uh you know I
loved them ever since
Kyle nervous were you with the Super
Bowl you know really nervous you know
ever when he when you play against Tom
Brady and you know that you know the
last time the was down you know in the
Super Bowl or any game you know when
he's down at half the UH he always makes
that comeback so it's you know that's a
half and in the Super Bowl you're it's
always in the back your mind that
Brady's gonna turn it on in the second
half where did you sit for the game like
50-yard line
like nice yeah it's good to be famous do
you get a Super Bowl ring I did not get
a Super Bowl ring yeah but you went to
how many games did you go to all the
home games majority of the home games
yeah and then I went to all the playoff
games so man step one my brother had a
my brother's wedding
you missed the first game who was there
thought of you know
going to the wedding so you wouldn't
miss the game it was close wait did you
tell him look dude I'm gonna go but I
don't want to be there I'd rather be at
the Eagles game okay
he knows how tired he was man I am and
he's obviously an Eagles fan as well so
we're obviously hoping you know they
moved on swing gets into the next game
do you have a favorite bat like nobody
touches this one favorite bat yeah um
like my own yeah or not no I don't say
bad I'm just I'm a guy that you know if
there's one game if there's their shapes
in it I keep it rolling and if there's
not I just he retired
wait wait wait when do you know when to
retire a bat no yeah but how do you know
there's no hits in it you go for four oh
four five now do you do you break the
bat do you toss it do you use it for
kindling in your fireplace like what
happens to that bad okay maybe give it
to a little cater what was your welcome
to the major leagues moment good or bad
welcome welcome to the major leagues
moment you could be facing somebody and
all of a sudden you go oh my god welcome
to the major leagues
yeah probably facing Scherzer how'd that
go
I was in the boxing for you before I
even stepped out I was oh - he's like
yeah there's just something about those
guys that it's just there are a lot of
great guys who are throwing but there
are certain guys that you just go oh my
god this a long day like this is really
work when you step in there was someone
like that it's a metal battle and it's a
grind you know
are you guys like that they usually 13
maybe 1 1 pitch you can you can hit and
if you fouled off
it's uh it you got to go on battle mode
so it's ease throwing all these pitches
and so for strikes and not because you
know hundred so it's uh not fair pretty
much hey congrats on the season so far
no numbers are fun and see at the
all-star game and also good luck with
your Eagles trying to repeat or say that
thank you thank you Michael yep
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]